[Musique]
après l'inauguration de deux robots
chirurgicaux dans les centres
hospitaliers de Versailles et de Poissy
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est au tour de
l'Hôpital Privé de l'Ouest parisien
situé à Trappes de bénéficier de cette
technologie le nom de ce robot d'avinci
x financé à plus d'un million d'euros
par le département il permettra de
maintenir une offre de chirurgie en
cancérologie de proximité ça va nous
aider à être plus précis dans le geste
et donc d'avoir plus d'Efficient dans la
gestion dans le traitement du cancer et
dans la limitation des effets
secondaires principaux qu'on peut avoir
parfois dans certaines choses
les conducteurs de bus Keolis à
Montesson ont entamé leur troisième
semaine de grève depuis le rachat de
leur dépôt par Keolis les salariés
constatent une dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail parmi elles
l'absence de versement des primes
d'intéressement et de participation une
reprise de l'activité mais pour le
moment pas prévue par les salariés suite
aux nombreuses affaires de harcèlement
scolaire en France et notamment dans les
Yvelines le Gouvernement présente ce
mercredi 27 septembre son plan contre le
harcèlement scolaire les particules
autour de trois axes prévenir détecter
et sanctionnés plusieurs mesures sont
prévues avec notamment une grille
d'auto-évaluation proposée aux élèves
pour se situer sur une échelle du
harcèlement une autre mesure concerne la
confiscation des téléphones portables ou
des réseaux sociaux dans le cas de
cyber-harcèlement